it's undetermined what ignited the fire
was it a Kia slam it was not a Kia you
just slandered a company and you're
gonna get sued
you idiot Nick what do you what are you
we're probably gonna get sued soon too
[Music]
there was a Florida woman
and she has been arrested and charged
after she she gets out of her car right
and she leaves her kids inside the car
right she has a couple kids in there all
right and she goes into it Dillard's do
you guys know what a Dillard's is yeah
yeah it's a department store all right
and she's in there with an unknown man
and she shoplifting [__] for like an
hour with him with the guy yeah and
she's just like scooping [__] up putting
her [__] purse putting under her
[__] shirt and all kinds of stuff
right and then when she leaves the store
she had the damnedest surprise and found
out that her car had been engulfed in
flames and completely emulated
yeah why because were they like I'll
show you the steel and then they were
burning her car down no oh the card like
just engulfed in flames somehow yeah so
she was doing like a grab-and-go and
then she was standing there with all the
loot and she's like my ghetto hey car's
on fire yeah was she more bummed about
that or her car was on fire or was it
because her kids were I think because
her kids were in there oh but it was oh
they're her kids were in there kids were
in there dude many kids were in there
many kids many kids how many kids would
you say like hers and her it says two
two kids that's a that's a sick ass loss
prevention tactic
so check this out that's so [__] up
the kids have Burns right that sucks but
they lift oh oh good good thankfully
because some nice people who are walking
by saw her car on fire and saw the kids
inside oh they got him out yeah they got
them out oh so they were like locked in
they were locked in there for an hour
she's doing a grab and go it took an
hour long that's not quite a crap that's
a shopping go dude she's definitely
checking out items before she steals
geez she was probably at like she was
really shopping putting it in the cart
and then she was ready to go and then
she just ran out like do I want to steal
this that is sometimes something you
consider I don't know if that ever
happened to you but like let's say I go
somewhere I need to get something real
quick
I'm like I could just run in real quick
for literally 30 seconds leave taika
here with the AC on keys in whatever but
then you're like but this is when crazy
[__] happens like people just jump drive
the car go so like that's actually what
happened we did a JK news where a guy
jumped in the car because the keys were
in it he left and he came back because
there was a kid in the back and if he
dropped off the kid and he scolded the
dude and he got in the car and he drove
off again
honor among Thieves what are the chances
you know I'm literally gonna go inside
grab this thing and then take off I
think I was actually getting like a
tiger's uh prescription yeah and I know
the pharmacy owner so it's gonna be fast
I already prepaid through whatever it's
just gonna literally be 30 seconds but
I'm still like better to keep the chance
at zero yeah yeah just because Anything
could happen at that time I like the
guys like be a better [__] dad dude
yeah it's back in the stone vehicle
like this you know what this is a car
back yeah
[Laughter]
five minutes
yeah God damn it I had to buy batteries
so now that she got stop taking your
wallet
all right she's got some burn kids now
just some bird kids got arrested too she
got arrested for neglect aggravated
child neglect and arsons yeah um it's
undetermined what ignited the fire was
it a Kia slam it was not a Kia you just
slandered a company and you're gonna get
sued
you idiot Nick what have you done we're
probably gonna get sued too I thought
you got my back dude
damn dude um she was also facing four
additional charges of Penny theft
battery and assault from previous
incidents it wasn't her first time okay
that was a surprise for me personally
but does that matter for for crimes of
this nature
um yes okay yes you know it's one of the
sickest things about Porsches they all
come with a little fire extinguisher and
you're like what the [__] are you gonna
use this but then like sometimes I I
think it might be handy to have one have
you guys ever had to use a small fire
extinguisher before never you know
there's barely anything in that [__]
yeah I don't even know how to use it
don't even bother with that [__] I've
had to put fires out
done that's it yeah it's barely anything
so what do you just spray on your face
you don't use it once so that's the most
important yeah I'm good yeah
[Laughter]
[__] that's why they always say just get
a full size that says a lot about the
type of people who drive that [__]
though yeah Porsches well yeah they're
like there's don't weren't as many fire
extinguishers inside because we know you
guys like the gun and around
you know what I mean like look what
happened with Paul Walker dude that guy
like zero to [__] 120 yeah hey the
kid the guy who was driving like into a
[__] embankment driving yeah a tree
yeah yeah bro that's scary what kind of
car was he driving Porsche 911 because
you which Porsche did you have it's 911
and it came with a little a lot of them
come with this where was I think all of
them was it in like the passengers it's
in a cool place like it's built into the
car so it looks built and then some of
them like it matches like the theme of
the car so some of them will be like
yellow if like the calipers are yellow
or whatever like they make it cool it
was a Carrera GTR retractment statement
okay of course a Porsche Carrera GT
that's a pretty hardcore one those are
pretty fast yeah this [__] is a grande
coffee dude there's nothing in it oh
like a small one because I've had to put
it homeless fires out in the alley like
outside my studio and that's all I had
and I'd saved it for this moment I was
like I'm gonna be a hero to the
neighborhood
[Laughter]
so what you do just start peeing on the
fire no I tried put it on another way I
used it up and like yeah there was some
in it it the fire got low for a second
and it just got bigger so I had to go
inside and get the full size the real
one yeah oh that's yeah but them small
things are just like for looks what's
the fastest you guys have gone in a car
and the Miata dude when I when you're
driving when you're the one driving yeah
dude I've I've been like I've I've taken
to like 105 bro do you drive pretty fast
no I drive a little girl really dude I
got my license suspended when I was uh
17 for going 115. it was suspended for
three months and I had to pay like 1700
bucks ruined my life I had to drop out
of Community College I have a whole a
quarter of all W's because I couldn't
get to school I think the fastest was
140. holy holy [__] what's it like
describe it it feels scary [__] fast
it feels pretty fast and you almost have
to like kind of find the right Road for
it it's not something where you're like
you got to go on a road that you know
you know that there's no potholes on
this road so I mean it was it was on the
10 freeway and you I know it's in this
Lane because there's potholes on that
lane I know it's not gonna be like when
there's a lot of other cars around
because it's one of those where like if
something happens you need a lot of
distance to bring it back down it's even
90. yeah because you can't hit the
brakes so one of my favorite places to
gun it is uh you know if you go on the
10 and then you go on the 710 North
you're gonna say like Valley Boulevard
that part's actually pretty smooth wow
so I've pushed uh I had a 911 I pushed
really hard there and then also had an
RS7 that I pushed pretty [__] hard
there too you know what's a fun thing
like even going the speed limit down the
110 when you're going towards Pasadena
it does feel like a race track a little
bit oh because of the ones though the
way that it turns yeah but no one knows
how to [__] know all the people
getting on the on-ramp have to stop
first yeah yeah that one's pretty cool
it is kind of cool I went 111 once
because I like the number
it was good luck but I did go to 111 and
I was like damn dude you make a wish
it's the fastest my body's ever moved
and I'm like no I don't plan to go like
500 miles but some cars like they're
meant to go fast so you could go 121 it
doesn't feel like it feels like you're
going 60 miles per hour yeah and in some
cars you'll go like 80 and you're like
yeah that's all the [__] I have when I
went above 100 in the Miata I felt like
the car shaking and I was like I'm good
dude in a DeLorean it's like they're
like 50 miles an hour you don't even
want to [__] yeah end this
speedometer only tops at 85.
that's so nice it's a joke trying to go
faster all the panels start getting gaps
oh geez that's scary it's scary then you
realize all the all the Foley from the
movie was just the actual car due to the
Miata sometimes when I break too hard my
radio would fly out
I think the max I went on my Land
Cruiser was 85 and I had and it was at a
steep downhill
deep downhill 85 bro like I'll be in
road trips going uphill and I'm behind
like I'm in the truck zone right because
like the oversized or whatever I'm on
the very right lane
there'll be trucks that are pulling
[__] RVs and a Jeep that's all tied
that are passing me up and I'm just like
[__] dude go yeah you wanna know some
real man [__]
more impressive than going fast on the
freeway go fast over speed bumps my guy
it feels like you're on a skateboard
going on I used to do that in Irvine in
my own in my own apartment complex when
I lived with my son and I would always
come home going in my Civic and then one
day you'll crack your tailbone dude
my Axel broke off completely and my mind
and I ran over my own tire and went
how much is that repair
I forgot about my dog's pissed then when
I had to call in a I called a Lifeline
into my job so it went up and then the
car just gets stuck right there
so though so the wheel fell off right
and then it and it goes over it like
this yeah and then and then the tire
goes on its side and now my car's just
on the tire no that must have been a
crazy sight to come out to yeah yeah you
must have been so scared that you're
like it's like watching your arm get
broken like it's not supposed to be like
well also it's like you did like it like
it's like what'd you do man this is
crazy [__] it's like I told my dad I was
the speed bumps are just high in my
complex dude like I was going the speed
limit all of a sudden because I didn't I
was broke because I was going to school
at the time and I was like I'm gonna pay
for this [__] was your dad like no you
did this you did the hard yeah of course
you did the horse place yeah well he has
facial guts all over as well yeah well
he's covering up a murder he did
yeah
so I thought it was a speed mountain
lion
yeah that's people came out of nowhere
and you can see the dumbest thing about
that is that like it could break the
ball joint but not come off that's even
worse because then I could be going
faster on the road and the same thing
what happened at a high speed that's a
danger and then that would have dragged
caught fire I'd be looking like a
totally different guy real hot guy
really tight cheekbones
[Music]